what name one horrible thing about the
manosphere that you wish was different
or you don't agree with
one
um
i don't agree with
the like cheating like high value men
have the right to cheat i like your
opinion on this um do tell
i
i don't think you have a right to cheat
on anyone and i think that if you want
to like make an arrangement with a girl
that's okay with it that's fine but the
whole like i can cheat as long as you
don't find out it's cool that's i don't
know that's i would be okay with that
yeah um what if you didn't know though
if i didn't know yeah
um
you know that philosophy thing i talk
about this so much it's not one that
comes to mind it's like if a tree went
down in a forest and you weren't there
did it make a sound it's like
well
we know that when
big things fall it will likely make a
sound right so when it comes to cheating
if you don't know can you be mad it's
like no but i would hope they don't do
it you know what i'm saying but that's
why i'm always saying like the inkling
thing i'm like if oh if i [ __ ] find
out excuse my language then now i'm
insecure
even though i should have been it's it's
more of an honesty thing
why why because
to me character is important and your
values are important yeah so
to me it's dishonest to the person that
you love more than anyone else in the
world that you want to spend the rest of
your life with yeah that you're lying to
them
do
i agree with you
i see your point
however do you think most women can
handle the truth
honestly um
no
so
if somebody either either find a girl
that would which there's a lot of girls
that will beyonce
there's a lot of people that aren't
getting laid pearl and you know it what
do you mean there are a lot of men that
aren't getting matched up that's a
problem right yeah that's a problem i
hate that i can't what is it
what does that have to do with cheating
so for you're saying that they should
find somebody that doesn't cheat oh
you're saying the girl find the guy
well i'm saying
do what works for you if
having your guy cheating you don't care
if you don't find out that's fine right
but i just think that in a partner that
i would look for like values and
character is important and i wouldn't
want to be with somebody that cheats
because
essentially you're lying to the person
that you want to spend the rest of your
life with i see what you're saying yeah
guys omission is a form of line i
googled that
just so we're clear like because people
tried to call cap on that on me and i
was like no omission's actually a lie so
i agree with that
um but i mean i i can't deny more high
value men are going to cheat duh yeah
than the average regular person
but a lot of times the manosphere just
acts like character isn't there and so
any guy given the opportunity is gonna
do it
um and i just disagree with that because
what would you define as character
somewhere on this one like in this case
it's telling the truth even when it's
hard okay i'm gonna google it for us
because i don't know i'm not trying to
like no you're okay
i'm like hoping that's why it [ __ ] is
i'm a [ __ ] okay
the men okay moral the mental and moral
qualities distinctive to an individual
a person in a novel play or movie okay
whatever that's like a character
character and i think a lot of times the
man of sphere they
what they're talking about
is women
wrecking their homes
over you know one instance and like not
even trying to work through it
i yeah they try to put it off like the
cheating doesn't hurt women
if she's leaving a marriage guys like
it's an issue
but
a man
was she different though i agree with
that i know i just i really want to
argue that one i don't like that one
but i i'm i think we're minorities and
this one to be honest with you we can be
picnics and [ __ ] but i i don't think
sorry i don't think that we're
like most women i really don't i think
that if
most women given the opportunity
if they were like this man cheated on me
i can do better i think they would be
delusional to think that
like at a certain age like they think
that they're so much better than the
dad
and you and i both agree that unless
there's abuse or is that just me
unless there's abuse in the home
right we like the parents to stay
together i'm talking like
like i my parents screamed at each other
my mother had mental illness we've
talked about this
i think i would be
so
much worse not saying that like i'm
awful but if my parents didn't stay
together i think i would have commitment
issues for sure
yeah i i think once you have kids it's
not about your feelings anymore thank
you yeah once once you have kids it's
not about you ladies stop thinking that
like that bothers me is there like adele
for instance she's like i had to do what
made me happy and made a whole album on
it yeah dude
and it's like i get that
but
i get it and i know it's so
controversial nowadays with feminism and
the moms are like you need to be
whatever and it's like but no it's not
about you your decision in this moment
that you might even that you will regret
let's be honest most women regret i
don't know the stat but they wish that
they didn't because they end up single
can somebody get the stat and put that
in the chat
but it's like why break up the home
for like when you'll get over it you
know what i'm saying i can't even think
of it i just the hard thing with
adultery and cheating is what are the
odds that a cheater actually stops
if they if you caught them you really
think that's the first time no not at
all so well cheating doesn't bother me
that's one thing yeah that's something
that there's something wrong with me
it's not normal i used to i used to i
used to get jealous but i think once i
when i went to vegas and i talked about
this in my earlier livestream today when
i went to vegas
you could say it's the epiphany phase
but like i was homeless dude like
and i felt so much better i felt safe
because i was i felt threatened at home
with
my family member with mental illness and
stuff so when i found myself let's say i
was finally at peace
with being alone because i felt safe
i wasn't feeling safe for a long time
and i was surrounded by family friends
whatever so for me when it comes to
cheating i just see it as another bump
in the road i don't know how those
correlate but there's something about it
that i don't get
maybe it's because i never had genuine
desire for somebody that's probably what
it was actually i don't know
you've have you ever dated somebody that
you didn't get jealous
that you didn't go through their phone
um
well the first guy that i was that i
dated
i never went through his phone because i
was very naive so i never like
i never even like thought that should we
tell them i didn't i didn't think people
should tell them what you're your thing
she's a phone
she's a phone looker i can't i'll i'll
get my feelings hurt that's what if i
don't see it
i don't care i really don't give a [ __ ]
no i
because you can get an std
like people like i think it's so someone
want to know something funny yeah go
ahead
you guys are gonna think i'm i'm so
sorry to all my exes this is gonna make
them look a little
i know it doesn't look good every single
guy that i so i started dating every guy
that i had sex with i never had sex with
him before i would demand an std test
before anything i don't give a [ __ ] is
this my camera i don't give a [ __ ] but
if he's cheating on you right so every
six months
that's what you do you if i'm gonna get
a checkup
so are you mm-hmm and you're paying for
it so i'm insurance
but yeah i don't care that's the thing
is like sure we can use the argument
that they're going to put our health at
risks most guys other than athletes will
use a condom on a side pitch
trust me
what about an sti
oh here we go
sti is
name one
what name one just so i'm like clear
oh gosh i have no idea okay hold on no
idea which one
listen if it's herpes you're asked i'm
not that that's what that that's for
life you know okay as but it's treatable
i've just heard there's stis that
condoms don't protect you from
they probably protect for most
you know like but you're not wrong yeah
it's just like why would you if you love
someone why are you gonna you know but
it what if i told you it's not about
love so like for us
cheating see it's hard because i'm
[ __ ] up dude like i don't get jealous
but i have before so i can i can
empathize the thing with men cheating
is it's not
it's some like a
like a twitch
in them it's like a what do we have
that's automatic what's something that
am i too low it's kind of hard to hear
me i don't know my stuff was so loud in
my ears tonight
well it's different i agree that it's
different for men and women i'm not
saying it's right
but it's not something that i have found
evidence that you can
excuse me change like
women adapt
we pick up on so many things
social cues like men what did rolo say
like the girl at the club that gives us
a weird look we see that men don't at
all they don't see it at all i remember
when i heard that i was like really not
even a little bit like you can't tell
no they can't so when i think about
things that
women typically i know it's so
complicated to make it gender specific i
don't want to do that but it's like
there's not enough research to get all
157 genders like like a good amount
a good group to test you know but what
i'm saying is
i don't think men cheat because they
don't love us i think they get in
relationships no i i don't disagree with
you i but i do think it's selfish why
because who else are you thinking about
when you're having like okay like it's
literally pleasure for me and i'm not
thinking about anyone else this could
potentially break up my home but i'm
gonna do this but that's your decision
to break it up
most guys don't leave if they get caught
cheating
well that's what i'm saying it's like
i know it's like makes sense but like
why
but when women understand that cheating
isn't
when you can get to a place where
cheating isn't a deal-breaker
because you don't know about it i'm not
saying that if you didn't find out you
wouldn't be pissed
you have every right to be but when you
realize why they do it it has nothing to
do if they love you i will say that it
probably has to do with you not giving
him something now if i'm not talking sex
there's something he's escaping from
maybe
but honestly
most men can't get women yeah i'm
putting it out there most of y'all can't
it's like the 2080 rule yeah yeah the
2080 rule yeah like so for me it's
almost like
if you can do that
do it
good for you
beat the odds like honestly but again
we're talking about
there's a possibility that they'll do it
that doesn't mean that the every single
dude will do it
what does donovan say i can't say it oh
women or men men don't cheat they have
not that
that one's a little that won't come out
of my mouth love you donovan but the one
that's like men are only
um cheating as often as as many options
as they have what is it
oh it's um okay under two 250 000
dollars the cheating like in income the
cheating rates 25 so one and four
but over two
250 thousand dollars it's 50 no like i'm
just saying that so so that that's data
that indicates that the more like
options a man has the more likely he is
to cheat but there's a way he says oh i
don't know it's like men are only
capable of having sexism as of like
if they have options they'll do it but
if they don't have options they won't
cheat because
how would they
unless